cs go skins you love them i love them
we all love them but they're expensive
the thing is
right now they're really expensive
so why is it that csgo cosmetics seem to
be undergoing yet another
boom and is it possible that it could be
turned into a sort of
shady pyramid scheme
[Music]
okay so before we start talking about
ops and whatnot i got to do the whole
plug thing
please please please like the video
subscribe to the channel
and make sure you turn on notifications
so that you never
miss a video even the ones about league
okay so if you are somehow unfamiliar
with how the whole cs go skin ecosystem
works
here is a very quick tl dr unlike the
vast majority of games in which skins
exist
and or matter such as league valorant
overwatch and siege cs go's cosmetic
infrastructure
is open meaning that items can actually
be listed on the steam marketplace or
traded directly between accounts what
this has given way to of course
is a beautiful awful and altogether
terrifying gray market in which skins
are bought
sold scammed gambled and traded on a
myriad of third-party sites that can
send
shivers up the spine of the unsuspecting
silver threes who use them but
use them they do since knives are shiny
and cool and look how flippy mine is
now in terms of how much these things
actually cost it
varies significantly whereas
run-of-the-mill cosmetics can fetch in
between
five and ten dollars others can
fetch in between five hundred and a
thousand
others still can fetch in between five
thousand
and ten thousand if not more now if you
don't know around this time
last year cs go skins began to undergo a
very significant
boom thanks to kovid cs go enthusiasts
around the world were
stuck at home with nothing to do and
nowhere to go
so in addition to playing a ton of
counter-strike
they began spending never-before-seen
amounts of money on it
over the course of the next six months
or so prices
skyrocketed and i mean skyrocketed
everything from knives to gloves to
so-called
high tiers dragon lores gungners and
certain sought-after dopplers etc
reached record levels of absurdity in
terms of what they fetched
and then in the fall things began to
slow down countries
slowly started to soften their
stay-at-home measures and
as expected player numbers started to
become reasonable again
then of course operation broken fang
happened
and after several weeks of complete and
utter stagnation
the market just went nuclear fast
forward to now
about half a year later and it feels as
if prices are doubling by the week
so what the [ __ ] happened well in an
effort to find out
i sat down with the homie zipple a
full-time skin trader who we did a
feature on last year
and who you definitely know if you
follow any cs go related accounts on
twitter
since his recent acquisition posts are
collectively
drooled upon by the cs community after
the operation or like when
when it's when it had been going on for
like a couple weeks only right and and
the
fate was out it was like going back and
forth not really making much progress
and it like dropped
in value was only one thousand dollars
and was like twelve hundred dollars
just going back and forth like seemed
like it was hard stuck same with all the
the high tiers like goony and stuff like
that but then
like during you know nearing the end of
the operation then
[ __ ] got crazy right because like now up
fate is 1902k
uh d-lords went to almost 10k everything
just like
spiked massively the question of course
was
why it spiked in such a way that you
know
nobody would rationally claim that that
was natural
like that it becomes very apparent that
these these large
large groups of investors have started
up started buying
large quantities of high-end skins and
then keeping them okay so it's probably
best if we
back up just a little bit in order to
best understand what zipple is actually
saying for several years now cs go skins
have been viewed as an
actual viable investment you bought them
or
unboxed them watched as the price kept
steadily going up and
thought to yourself [ __ ] i could sit on
these and
actually stand to make a pretty penny
and then somewhere along the way
cs go got big in china before long you
had this massive influx of newly minted
csgo fanatics
who in addition to boasting a fair bit
of disposable income
were putting an unprecedented amount of
demand
onto a market that hadn't really been
built to offer that
kind of supply what were previously rare
but
attainable treasures howls cattle
hollows
souvenir dragon lores etc had become
incredibly sought after commodities that
were
doubling tripling quadrupling and in
some cases
quintupling in price last week for
instance we did a don't at me on a cs go
skin that was privately traded for a
hundred and fifty thousand us dollars
supposedly breaking the all-time record
for the most expensive counter-strike
cosmetic ever
sold what's crazy is that apparently
it's already worth more than that like
much more so where was all of this
happening well
i'll tell you this it sure as [ __ ]
wasn't on the steam market
it was on buff buff 163 or just
buff is both china's go-to third-party
skin shop
and unsurprisingly the single largest
marketplace for cs go cosmetics
in the world if you ever want to know
what your inventory is
actually worth check buff it's basically
the cs go skin traders bible
before you'd have multiple sites and
you'd have you know reddit determining
prices and all sorts of things but now
everything is just on buff so if the
price
is 10k above that's the price that's
what it's worth
because there's so much volume so much
sales like nothing compares to it
so if you are successful with moving the
price on buff
it's very likely that you've moved in on
every marketplace
and according to zipple it was because
of buffs monopoly
the fact that price changes on it are so
influential
and the leniency of the site's so-called
failure to deliver mechanic that the
recent
spike in prices even came about in the
first place
you have one butterfly sapphire listed
for 10k that's the cheapest listed
then you have maybe 10 more listings but
after the 10
listing is bought the next price is 11k
or 12k so if somebody were to go on buff
and buy 10 butterfly sapphires what
would happen is that the 10 people that
need to deliver this
knife would then go on their buff up and
they would see that the new price is 12k
so half of these people won't even
deliver the knife because they're now
like they're now you know aware that the
price is now 12k
so they will actually be convinced that
now there's a new price
for the knife so this guy actually
didn't even have to buy 10 knives to
move the price
of what 10 knives would have you know
resulted in he just had to buy 10 and 5
wouldn't deliver the knife and now
those people who didn't deliver it are
now thinking you know
my knife is worth 12k and they're not
going to ask lower than that
so that kind of just like builds and
builds and builds so
why does this matter well for starters
these price hikes can stack
meaning that these tiny little
manufactured inflations can
add up and drastically raise the price
of a skin in a very short period of time
but what zippo also observed is that
it's almost
always the same types of buyers who were
responsible for them
hoarders and i started looking at the
buyers they were all the same it was
like
four five six guys all the same accounts
they had like storage units and then
what was visible in their inventory was
like either
50 pairs of ice gloves or 500 of the
same sticker
or 150 emperor m4s
so just like a multitude of of various
items like
so many different items but in large
large quantities and none of them had
played an hour cs go the question of
course
is what happens if these select few
traders decide to
unload their treasure trove of skins all
at once
well according to zipple it
wouldn't be great hundreds of the same
really really expensive skins
so if they decide one day you know now
we just dump all of it
it'll be ugly right we're definitely
dealing with like some really large
groups of of chinese investors who are
just
buying massively into the market and
none of us knows if they're doing it to
for a quick pump and dump or they're
doing it for like long term maybe
they're selling next year
i don't know if it's scary but it's a
little bit scary to think that you know
they can
literally flip the market overnight with
the amount of items they're holding
now to be fair zipple doesn't actually
think that these investors would do that
since it would all but destroy the
market that they stand to make such a
killing off of
he thinks that they're more likely to
try to repeat this process over and over
they don't they don't want to push the
prices and dump it everybody will be
aware
of what they're doing and then you know
nobody's ever gonna believe when prices
go up again
here's where things get really crazy
then like put on your tinfoil hats crazy
according to zipple there's a sense in
which the repeatability of this whole
venture is
even scarier since theoretically
it could create some very fertile ground
on which to build
a pyramid scheme you'll have some people
who'll start buying up the items early
they'll be the ones that profit the most
they'll be the ones that sell the items
first and then you have
you know say that you buy up all the the
the d-lords at 9k now they're 10k and
a lot of people start listing them again
for 9k they go to 8.8 k they go to 8.5 k
then the initial investor if he's
skilled enough he can just get more
people to join him and buy up all those
as well
so he can you know get that margin that
he wanted initially when he started
buying all these steelers
now to be clear zipple isn't claiming
that a pyramid scheme currently exists
or at the very least that there isn't
any concrete evidence of one
what he is saying is that in his expert
estimation
it is very possible that this whole
thing
could turn into one you have to remember
like cs go skins have pretty much
reached the point of a [ __ ]
cryptocurrency
there is tons of money to be made and
zero
regulation with stonks you can go to
federal prison for things like insider
trading
with cs go skins not so much
it's the same with like penny sucks and
[ __ ] right so i can go to someone and
say
hey this uh this delore is a great price
at ten thousand dollars
and i can have 100 people buy it and now
it's uh 13
you know and i managed to pick up 50 at
eight right what's also crazy
is that this has actually happened
before
ever played runescape yeah then you know
just how this stuff can actually get
that's the same thing that happened in
runescape
if you played that ever it's like you
have merch clans
where where it literally happened like
this they find an item
they buy it slowly over three weeks so
the price doesn't increase at all
when they've stocked up on everything
they go to all the plebs in the clan
that they've been advertising for with a
thousand people and then they tell them
buy this item up we're gonna make it
explode
and then as soon as they bought
everything they start offloading
because all the other people still have
trade look and then they just start
selling their [ __ ]
and then they don't give up what happens
from there and then they just repeat it
again
okay so why does any of this matter to
you
after all you're not a full-time trader
you don't make a living
buying and selling clean ass ops you're
just an
average everyday gold nova who dreams of
owning a butterfly knife that doesn't
have
camo on it well here's the thing thanks
to these
investors you may just have to settle
for
boreal forest for a little while longer
or like you know forever memes aside
what this means is that the value of
certain high tiers
has skyrocketed so astronomically
that they've essentially become ultra
high tiers
right now maybe 60 of the butterfly
sapphires are
on idle accounts or with with people who
are flipping them or investing in them
and not even playing the game so what is
happening is that
these really high tier items are
kind of being taken away from the hands
of the active players the other issue is
the trickle-down effect
you see as these so-called ultra-high
tiers become increasingly unattainable
so too does everything else
what was considered heights here two
years ago will kind of shift into
something else
the high tier items have just gotten
that much more high tier
if that makes sense so essentially it's
just
like if if a butterfly fate becomes two
thousand dollars
whereas it was before three hundred
dollars then
that's not obtainable for a lot of
people that's the price of a butterfly
sapphire three years ago i hate to say
it but
i think it's gotten to the point where
if you don't already own a dragon lore
gangneer or whatever other grail to your
skin you dream about
it's safe to say you never will these
things aren't just
pipe dreams anymore they're fictions
the upside of course is that today's
mid-tier is
fated to become tomorrow's high tier so
don't despair if a doppler phase 2 was
the best you could do
pretty soon that [ __ ] could be stocks
you know i think that as
time passes by it also becomes like
it also it's not like people will always
think that you know
the goal for me is the battle scar
dragon lord because people will adjust
their expectations to the price of the
item
so probably if
prices continue to go up then in a
year's time maybe it's like
really insane if somebody has a m9
doppler in like a regular phase two or
four in a game as for where the ceiling
on all of this is
who knows man zippo says it's gotten to
the point where he's refusing to
acknowledge that a limit even exists
all i'll say is that if there is a limit
i don't even want to know what it is i'm
not going to say that there is a
roof anymore because i've said i thought
to myself
at every stage i've had an item that is
now 20k and i would think at 2k this is
the top 5k this is the top 10k this is
the top 20k this is the top and i just
keep being wrong so i'm not gonna say it
anymore
i feel like you're i feel like you're in
you're you're you're an m9
bayonet fade you know yeah rugged
reliable and classic
classic never that's the thing about the
the m9 fade man never goes out of style
never goes out of style always a nice
have not not not the most expensive skin
not the cheapest either fetch is a
pretty penny but
it is just like the ultra mid tier it's
just like it's like the fade is like
never goes out of style devin you're
mid-tier devon you're mid-year but
you are the best you are the best
mid-tier